All right.
I'm Alan Pike.
And today I'm going to be sharing some
of what we've learned building voice in
visuals out
experiences using AI.
Here we go.
So this
is Andrej Karpathy.
And he made an argument last month
that voice
is the human preferred input
for AIs.
But that we prefer visuals as the
output.
And
he knows a thing or two about this
stuff.
But that's not how we have been for the
most part building
or using
AI.
We've been typing to it.
It's been typing back maybe with some
markdown.
But there's some real breakthroughs over
the last few months
where
both of this
visuals in and audio or the audio in and
visuals out experience is now um really
feasible. We can create really
delightful experiences with it.
The visuals outside
is pretty intuitive, right? Of course
a third of our brain is dedicated to
processing visual information. We love
looking at things.
And models have recently got to the
point where they can generate rich HTML,
tool calling.
So we can have these experiences where
there's visualizations that come back,
explain things, help us understand,
communicate the the responses from these
models. They can give us interactive um
controls that allows to explore and
understand and modify and change and and
and direct the models.
And they can even respond with beautiful
illustrations and images, right?
And so
the the ceiling on the visuals out piece
has really lifted and we have a lot more
capability of what we can do in terms of
responding from these models.
The more controversial half of
Karpathy's argument though is this idea
of voice as the preferred input.
We've long sort of
idealized and fantasized about speaking
to an AI and having this real-time
conversation where it understands what
we need and it and it reacts
appropriately in real-time.
But the experiences that most people
have had so far with voice interfaces
have been more like trying to get Siri
to turn the lights on and it's not
working or like this guy
that is like trying to get ChatGPT voice
mode to do things, but it keeps being
like awkward and confused, right? The
models that we have so far, the
experiences that people most people have
seen
are both
slow and dumb, which is like not a great
combination.
And so a lot of people are down on
voices as an input.
But speaking
is the ultimate way that as humans we
communicate.
When we're speaking, we have more words
per minute than when we're typing.
But we also convey more with each word.
There's a huge difference in between if
you say to me
okay
versus if you say
okay.
And that's why when we have something
that is really important that we need to
communicate
or get through to somebody,
we will jump on a call.
And we will or we'll speak in person.
So that we can get through that high
bandwidth
uh communication.
Um and so
what we've done at Forest Walk is we
have built an agent that is in our calls
that can help us out in real time.
And so the other day I mentioned to my
co-founder in call on a call that
I'd seen a bug
with the Slack integration or at least I
thought I had.
And she responded that she had seen
the same bug.
And so I just said, "Okay, well, let's
file that
as a Linear issue."
And the voice agent within a second
responded that it had done so.
And that feels perfectly natural when
you get it really dialed in.
That you have are speaking either
incidentally or you know, with a purpose
intentionally speaking to
the AI and it responds in a way that is
not interruptive of you. It doesn't need
to be voice. It is
just taking action on your intent.
And so this is we're going to see this
experience more and more in the coming
months and years.
But there's a huge barrier, a huge
challenge to making this actually work
and feel good.
And that is the tyranny
of latency.
It's
really difficult to get a response
through that whole chain fast enough. We
we've known since the '60s that
to have a computer react to us fast
enough that it feels
instant, it needs to react in about 100
milliseconds, a tenth of a second.
And so of course we are always aspiring
to get our products to react that fast.
And sometimes we can achieve that, but
with networking and everything it can be
challenging depending on what work needs
to get done. And so sometimes we might
flex up to a thousand milliseconds.
Right? You get a full second. It's about
the limit before people start to lose
their train of thought. They ask Siri to
do something, takes more than a second,
we're off to something else mentally,
right?
And so we're always in that play in
between those two kind of human limits
of
trying to respond within a second,
ideally within 100 milliseconds.
But if we want to have a seamless voice
conversation with it an AI or another
human,
the limit is much more
aggressive.
We need to have a 200 millisecond
latency or less if we want to have a
fully conversive people are verbalizing
something and they are interrupting or
interjecting or agreeing
and forming that sort of connection
for a full voice in voice out uh
conversation.
Um
and so imagine trying to do that where
you have a network request, uh maybe you
take turns speech to text, uh and then
you do some sort of model inference on
that text, and then send it back on the
network. It's like a ridiculous
uh amount of of work to do in 200
milliseconds. Um
there are some clever approaches of
trying to work around that. Uh Thinking
Machines and Neolab has uh a really
thoughtful architecture where they were
demoing recently, um
just a few weeks ago, a they've time
sliced into 200 millisecond chunks like
that 200 millisecond goal, and and has a
model that's doing continuous inference
in and out at 200 millisecond slices.
Um so there are ways around it
for voice in voice out, but there's also
just we don't need to wait for novel
architectures.
We can just switch to having voice in
visuals out
and then we benefit from the more
forgiving visual response envelope that
people have. That if you have something
that appears on screen within a second
of what you've you've said, it feels
like it has met that it's keeping with
within your attention span. It's
reacting to you in a way that feels
seamless.
Um and so we've been building for that
over the last few months and it's a lot
of fun and we've learned a lot doing
that. And so I want to finish up just by
sharing three of the things that we
found um to be really important for
getting within that latency envelope and
making the experience feel really
delightful um
for for people who are using it.
So the first one is that in order to
respond in a way that feels seamless,
you have to use a really fast model.
Cuz that's not just a model that is so
small
um
that it can respond fast enough in a few
hundred milliseconds. Of course it it
does need to be. Um but it also has to
be on an inference platform that
prioritizes latency.
So when GPT-5 mini came out, we were
excited that
um that okay, well, yeah, we get this
more intelligent model and presumably
it'll be fast. But then in practice we
were seeing latencies of 5,000
milliseconds, 7,000 P95, sometimes
10,000 millisecond latency for this
small model. It was cheaper than the
bigger model,
but we weren't consistently or even ever
seeing it respond fast enough.
Um Haiku is much better
um in terms of of that that P95 latency.
So, you you really need a a kind of a
Haiku class model as the one that's
responding in this real-time and and or
one of the smaller open-source ones.
And then if there is a larger chunk of
work that needs to get done, then that
model then hands off or sends off an
asynchronous message to a larger model
that can think, and then the continuous
real-time model or soft real-time model
that's responding quickly then can re-
interleave in those responses if it's
doing something heavier.
Um so, that's number one you need to
have a fast model. Obviously, with a a
short enough context that you're
providing it that it can respond in a
few hundred milliseconds.
Um
the second thing that's really critical
if we're going to have this feeling of
it being really responsive is to have
short intervals
of how quickly we're sending out for
inference.
So, traditionally for like a voice
application, you might listen to the
user for a few seconds and then they
stop, you listen for a second of
silence, and then you have uh some sort
of inference goes on, and then you're
you're blown your budget by a pretty
wide margin just for waiting for
silence.
So, if we're going to have our
something up on screen within a second,
um then when we want to have our
inference pretty eagerly responding as
the person is talking, even if we're not
entirely sure they've stopped talking,
being willing to send inference every 1
or 2 seconds as they speak cuz you know,
we sometimes have a sentence where, you
know, we ask, "Oh, hey, we're going to
want to change this and actually also
list to this other thing." It feels much
more seamless if you're doing those
things as people talk. Um so, you have
to have a a model and an an
infrastructure where you're able to get
these fast turns going.
And then finally,
in order to actually make all of that
work, you need to have a stable caching
regimen.
So, we have this huge
improvement in the way that we work with
LLMs over the last year where
we have on the different platforms
different ideas of this prefix caching
where if the beginning of the context
you send to the model is the same each
time, then you can get up to 90%
cheaper, faster inference um depending
on the conditions. And so, you need to
lean heavily into this
architecture really I think for for most
applications we're moving towards this,
whether it's like a long-running agent
or it's a frequently running agent, the
same principle applies that we want to
the first 90% of the context window if
we can to be the same from request to
request, and then just use that final
10%, and then also, of course, minimize
the number of output tokens so that you
can get these really fast and relatively
affordable inference turns to create
that that delightful experience.
Um
So, these are some of the the techniques
we've found really useful. Um I would
love to hear from anybody who um has
been exploring and experimenting,
whether it's with real-time or any way
that people are pushing the boundaries
of
creating delightful experiences uh with
these models. Uh I'd love to chat, share
what we've been learning.
Uh and I hope some of this inspires some
of you to go out and uh build something
great.
Thanks.